معنى من لندن الدكتور فرانك لجويتش الخبير
العسكري والضابط السابق في المخابرات
العسكريه البريطانيه البريطانيه اهلا
وسهلا بك
دخول طائرات الاواكس اذا سلمنا انها ستدخل
بدايه من الثلاثاء المقبل في رومانيا ما
الذي ستضيفه
[موسيقى]
احتمالات اداء في خاصه في الجو ان يتوقعوا
ان يعرف ماذا يحدث من احداث في اوكرانيا
حقيقه ان هناك 14 طائره وموده
وهناك ثلاثه
الى رومانيا من المفروض ان توفر هذه
الطائرات القدره على المراقبه الجويه على
مدار الساعه طبعا هذا الطائرات سبق لها
وان نشرت غربه وشرق
الاوكراني لكن لم تكن همم تحطه في
المطارات الرومانيه الان
انطلاقها من هذه البطاله تصير رومانيا
سيعطيها كفاءه اكثر من ذي قبلك لكنه لا
يغيروا حقيقه انها كانت تحلق في سماء
المعركه او بمحاذاه المعركه منذ بدء الحرب
ولكن هل هل يمكن ان تغير سير المعارك في
فتره قريبه وجيزه
حقيقه
هذه الزمن لكن ما تضر عليه هذه الخطوه ان
حلف النيته من خرط بشكل كامل على الاقل في
المجال الاستخبارات من وجهه نظرته هذا هم
يحتاجونه بحكم الضروره الى المراقبه
الاحداث ومن وجهه نظر واشنط تقديم اماكن
نشر هذه الطائرات قد ينظر اليها انها قد
لا تكون خطوه عزائيه لكنها على الاقل ليست
دفاعيا واعتقد ان هناك اهميه ومغزه في هذه
الخطوه ولكن هل هذا يمكن ان يستفز روسيا
وتقول لها همم طريقه للرد بشكل او باخر
اف اف
ترد على
نشر طائرات استخباريه
لفعل ذلك من قبل لكن طالما
طالما ان هذه الطائره
بروسيا الى تحديها وربما بشكل مباشر او عن
طريق الخطا لكن هذه الطائرات لا تعمل
لوحدها هي دائما ترافق بطائرات وقاتله
لحمايتها وفي الحقيقه الدور الاساس هنا في
المعارك سيكون
لطائرات المقاتل اذا عندما تكون هناك
طائرات مقاتله حوالين ميدان المعركه هذا
واضح انه قد يظهر في عين بس يا كاسترزاز
لكن انهم هم ان لم يستجيبوا بشكل ما حتى
الان بعد مرور هذه الاشهر اعتقد انهم شكرا
نشر هذه القوات الهذا الطائرات وهناك
دائما خطوره في القران
شكرا لك